さんこんにちははじめしゃちょーですと
いうわけでNBAの伝説的な選手
レジェンドが3編今日本に来ております
[音楽]
こんなスタッフいるんだっていうNBAの
凄さを感じでおりますが今回なんと
プレゼントnvd選手3人と
343ができます
いやもう
貴重よMVファンからすると本当に
知らない人がいないくらいもうレジェンド
選手が来られているみたいで
あんまり
詳しくなくてですねこれを3ということで
戦えない
助っ人2人
呼んでおりますどうぞ
てくださいはじめしゃちょーの畑の
ツイートはじめ社長の僕もよろしくお願い
しますアメリカですかここ安城の183
です身長何cm186です
身長186です
でけえ俺がでかいですよねそして3人とも
バスケ経験者ということで
俺の周りに戦えるんだったらこの3人が今
ベストメンバーということでちょっと
はじめしゃちょー界隈の
本気のメンバーでNBAのレジェントに
対決を見たいと思いますお願いします2
Kっていうゲームやってました
神様じゃないですか
冗談だと思った
スケジュールがカツカツというか忙しいの
で皆さんもう時間を塗ってこの後できるか
もしれないということで
聞きあれば戦っていきたいと思います
頑張っていきましょう
[音楽]
というわけでnbagentと3O3
さあいよいよ始まりました
試合がスタートしましたもういきなり
シュートもう
柔らかけー
絶句しております始めチーム俺はうま
すぎるそんなところで諦めた時にね
釣りオンスリーは
連続でシュート入れたチームのえーお
フェーズになりますので続けてnblz
はい外れた
リバウンドしかったな
5分でどれぐらい点差がつくというかどう
なるんでしょうねただ観客が多いですね
すごいたくさんの方に見られております
いやちょっとこれもらったもうどうも先生
の首都が外れて性格ボールを
キープパス
弟にバス音を出すここから緑
外れたやっぱNBA2はジャンプしなくて
もボールが取れます
再びレジェンドチームです
その
身長差と
どうすんの身長差
止め方知りたいよ本当にさすがです武藤も
デカすぎる2m20cm
サボっていた
深いドリブルが
毎回見てみましょうこの
ドリブルが深すぎるよさすがにプレゼント
こんなのずっと飛べるやん
かっこいい誰もそんなドリブル曲がったら
いいなこの身長で
さあ続けてレジェンドチームです攻撃が
続きます高
[音楽]
すぎる止められないシュートどうするどう
すんのそれパスそしてハードウェイプ
そこからシュート
くれ
大丈夫事故事故動画になっちゃうけど
なんもない計算になってきてますこれが
NBAレジェンド
現金滞在されてもこの強さなのかパス
旅人選手が
回ってきたよこれで
止めたいところではあります
あと2点さあ
再び攻撃ですここで一気に点差を詰めたい
外すわけにはいかない中で弟にバス
戻す
シュート
外すが
弟が取るGoogleついに戻す
外から3ポイントやったかこれは
エアーボール
相手がねやっぱこの
有名なセッションで緊張してるんだよな
おっとなんでこんなスクリーンはありなの
かここで
外す
[音楽]
プリント見せかけてバック
ステップ3
よしまだまだあるか再び攻撃です
まだ
あるか残り1分ですさあ
逆転できるか大丈夫か
スクリーンからの開いてオープン
タップパスついのシュート
外れてリバウンドは弟が取るよく走った
働け
バイト
しました
ここは何としても決めたい
ここでようやく本気を出してきたから
食べるぞテストが超ディフェンスがガチに
なってきてる
ちょっと
相手が突然ここで本気出してきたな
ちょっときつかったんでついにしました
手堅く似ているのも大事です残りの時間で
ここで逆にしたいそれで距離の3
[音楽]
じゃないか残りが5秒かな
終了ですなんか涙がいい試合になった動画
のかと思いましたがいい試合になりました
手を抜いてくれてありがとう
レジェンドNBAの皆さん
綺麗な感じ
[拍手]
でーす
[音楽]
一人でお疲れ様でしたお疲れ様でした
どうでしたもうビビりました
謎の緊張感が
すごい圧迫感があるでしたいやマジで
デカかったないねうとんぼ選手でかすぎ
でしょ
北京大されたら動きだから本当にすごい
ことですねはいもうNBに
バスケットボール界に歴史を刻んだ方達な
ので本当に貴重な経験をさせて
いただきますけどね
実は私の
フレンズオブNBAということで招待され
ておりまして今後日本でもジャパンゲーム
やったりとかってすごいnbmに上がるの
で僕も一緒にNBA盛り上げていければ
いいなと思っております
本当にその経験の時もありがとうござい
ましたありがとうございました
次は立ちます
OKですOK出してちょっと
[音楽]